hello you're watching Sky News and we
have some breaking news for you this
hour Nicholas sturgeon is to resign as
first minister of Scotland she was of
course the first female first Minister
and the first woman to lead any of the
devolved UK administrations so breaking
news here on Sky News Nicola sturgeon is
to resign as the Scottish first Minister
let's take you straight to Westminster
and correspondent Tamara Cohen is
standing by with more information
tomorrow we only heard just a short
while ago that she's set to hold a press
conference and now you understand that
she is to resign
yes dramatic and significant news coming
from Scotland we heard in the last few
moments that Nicholas sturgeon is to
hold a surprise press conference this
morning and a senior Scottish government
Source has told Sky News they expect
Nicholas sturgeon will be resigning at
that press conference after eight years
as first minister of Scotland really big
moment for the SNP Nicholas sturgeon who
looked unassailable in terms of her
popularity in Scotland even months or in
the last year there's been little
question about her staying on at the
helm is now we understand going to be
standing down and triggering a
leadership contest for who leads at the
SNP and the Scottish government into the
future
undoubtedly she's had a difficult time
over the past few months her decision to
bring in a law relating to gender
identification which put her on a
collision course with Westminster
leading the Westminster government to
block that was seen as actually a bit of
an own goal for the SMP on an is it
seemed the Scottish public did not
necessarily agree with her there's also
been a wave of industrial action with
teachers and NHS workers in Scotland
going on strike as we've seen in the
rest of the country her own popularity
has certainly taken really an unusual
knock in the last few weeks and months
in recent polls for the first time
really since she became first Minister
and so dramatic news we expect from
Nicholas sturgeon who of course has been
involved in Scottish nationalist
politics all of her life taking over
from Alex salmond after the independence
referendum back in 2014. of course she
had tried to get the Supreme Court to
rule that another Independence
referendum could be possible and they
ruled against her another setback back
in October last year so she gives up the
leadership of the SMP with I'm sure she
will be saying many achievements to her
name but certainly it's been a difficult
few weeks and months for the first
Minister and this looks like really a
turbulent time for Scottish politics
with no obvious successor waiting in the
wings